Here we have a square,
on which all sides are x long.
Here I want to think about it
whether the perimeter of the square
is directly proportional to the length of the square.
Let's think a little.
I'll draw a table,
I'll make a few columns.
Here she is,
I will make three columns,
as in the first
we will look
the length of the country.
It is measured as x.
In the next column we'll look at the tour.
How is this?
This will be x plus x, plus x, plus x,
which of course is 4x.
Then I want to look at the attitude.
The relationship between the perimeter
and the length of the country.
What is the tour,
when the length of the country is equal to 1?
It will be 4 by 1.
1 plus 1, plus 1, plus 1.
It will be 4.
And what is the attitude?
It will be 4 to 1,
which of course equals 4.
But what if the length of the country is 2?
Then the tour will be
2 plus 2, plus 2, plus 2.
The tour will be 4 by 2.
So 8.
Therefore, the ratio will be 8 to 2,
which will be equal to 4.
I think we found some kind of dependence here.
It seems that the attitude of the tour to
the length of the country will always be 4.
We can go on here.
If the length of the country is 3,
then the tour will be 12.
What is the attitude?
12 divided by 3 equals 4.
This is not a magical trick,
because to find the tour,
we multiply by 4.
The relationship of the circumference to the length of the country
always
will be 4x,
if the length of the side is x,
and 4x divided by x,
it will always be 4.
Well, that's what our condition is
to have a straightforward relationship.
The relationship between the circumference and the length of the country
it will always be 4.
There was no need to make this table here,
but it makes the task a bit more specific.
Or we can write it in the following way:
we can write that
the tour
of the square
is equal to 4 times the length of the country.
To repeat - it is clear,
that we have a direct relationship.
The tour is equal to a constant across the country,
or the circumference divided by the length of the country,
is equal to 4.
We definitely have a direct relationship
between the length of the country and the circumference.